reject I can everyone hear me okay at
the back it's fine yeah okay cool I will
just start by saying thank you very much
for having me to speak it's an
incredible honor and a pleasure to be
here and to be part of this great
JavaScript community maybe I'll start
and introduce myself a little bit my
name is Melanie I'm lead web developer
and co-founder of little web giants
we're a small digital agency we do
websites and online marketing I am
actually pretty much a self-taught
developer my background is in
environmental activism and social
justice work so I'm not really here to
talk to you about any kind of like
amazing higher-level cutting-edge
brand-new acma script stuff I'm kind of
reporting back from the trenches of some
practical stuff that I've experienced in
my work and wanted to kind of share with
you guys today in our work we do sorry
we do a lot of work with not-for-profit
organizations and the renewable energy
industry and as part of this we're
working a lot with organizations that
are receiving government funding and
this kind of plays into why I became
really interested in this topic of
accessibility because will first start
often if you're receiving government
funding there is some compulsion that
you should meet a minimum accessibility
requirements in the web products that
you develop and I think also it's it's
for me a really burning an important
issue because I think access to the
internet and access to all the
information and tools and communities
that are available online is an
incredibly transformative and powerful
thing in people's lives and at a time
when we're seeing the Internet is kind
of becoming more closed and more
proprietary software and kind of closing
off into these
war gardens ensuring that everyone
everywhere has access to free and open
education and free and open Internet I
think is really one of the most
important social justice issues of our
times so today I'm just going to show
you some kind of little tips and tricks
that you can use to hopefully not so
much effort to implement but can
actually really radically transform how
accessible your web projects are to a
wide range of people okay so starting
from what do we mean by accessibility
when we hear this word we often tend to
think of it in terms of our we need to
cater for people who have specific
disabilities we can kind of broadly
break this down into people with some
sort of visual impairment or the blind
auditory unable to hear a cognitive
issue so this might be either an
intellectual disability or a learning
disability or people who just their
first language is not the language of
the website in question and then finally
we have motor disabilities so this is
relating to how well or how not well
you're able to to move which of course
then relates to how well you're able to
control a mouse and a keyboard so we
tend to kind of think of these groups as
being served by specific assistive
technologies so if you have visual
impairment then some of the tools you
might use include screen readers so on
Mac there's the voiceover for windows
there's this software called jaws other
approaches we can take as designers and
developers is to ensure our designs are
very legible you know not kind of too
cluttered and things like this if
there's auditory impairment then we can
kind of serve people who have this
problem through the use of subtitles or
the use of alternative text for audio or
video content for people who have some
sort of cognitive impairment then it can
be really really useful to a supply
alternative content in the form of
simpler text it's easier to understand
and maybe supplemented with images as
well
in Germany there's like this kind of
concept is actually formally legislated
and it's known as lactis rocker so
that's easy speech and you can actually
hire someone who will do translation
from kind of normal German to this
lightish barca for you and then finally
when we're looking at motor impairment
then we tend to think of how can we make
our websites navigable using the
keyboard so that people who maybe are
not able to control a mouse particularly
well have an alternative way to access
the information on a website so this is
quite a sort of literal interpretation
of what accessibility means so we
identify a disability or a set of
disabilities and then we identify the
assistive technologies that we should
work to support but I do like to think
about accessibility as a little bit more
broad than that as I said earlier I
think it really comes down to a big
social justice issue and so it could be
more than just people that we would
consider as following under some kind of
banner of disabled so accessibility is
also thinking about how do we make our
work inclusive to people across a whole
range of age spectrums how do we reach
out to older people how do we make sure
that information is also accessible to
younger people people might have
different educational cultural
backgrounds so if you're seeking to
provide information maybe you need to
think about the sort of stories or
metaphors or parables that you're
telling that might not apply to certain
cultural groups that you're trying to
reach and depending on the purpose of
your project Internet bandwidth may also
be an accessibility issue you know if
you're trying to send like 20 megabytes
of really beautiful high-resolution
images down the line to someone in like
sub-saharan Africa you're not really
serving them at all so it really can
depend on the needs of your project but
I think thinking about accessibility is
really thinking in his broad terms as
possible how do we reach an audience
serve an audience and empower people
so I'm going to talk briefly about the
kind of legal frameworks that exists and
some of the like w3c specifications that
exist that we should be trying to fall
in line with technically and then in the
final part of the talk I'll talk a
little bit more about how you can apply
that in a more practical sense i'll try
and whip through this legislation stuff
because it's a bit boring okay so we
have the UN Convention of Human Rights
of Rights with persons with disabilities
sorry recognizes access to the web as a
right that should be respected a basic
human right so we I think have a really
strong ethical obligation as people who
are very empowered who are very savvy
users of technology to make sure that
other people who might not have the same
access and the same rights and abilities
as us are able to to get that access as
well and there are legislative
frameworks to support this so I'm
familiar particularly with Germany the
UK and a little bit the US but there's
frameworks in other countries as well
this doesn't usually apply to the
private sector but it will apply to
government organizations and too many
nonprofit organizations that receive
government funding so it's kind of good
to be aware of these basic frameworks
unfortunately it's quite hard to find
practical examples of how to take this
legislative framework and the rules and
the specs and turn it into something
practical that you can kind of just use
in your everyday workflow and I kind of
think of this a little bit like maybe
four or five years ago and you had this
problem with like two floated divs and
then the next dave is coming up here and
you're like what's going on and then
you're like ah I need your clear fix get
down there div do what you're supposed
to be doing and and there was like this
kind of whole debate in the community
how do you achieve this really simple
layout of like to give thanks to each
other and one underneath and now we just
have the CLE fix and if you're like me
you just like at include feet clear
fixin and you're done and that problem
is kind of being solved by the community
and there's a default kind of
a of just making that work which I don't
think really exists for a lot of this
stuff that we're talking about in terms
of how to make websites more accessible
so one of the things I'm trying to do
here today is to give you some kind of
practical stuff that you don't need to
think about too much to just apply okay
so then we come to standards and specs
w3c of course big bad boss of the
Internet's they have to kind of relevant
specs that we can use as guidelines for
what we should be doing in our web
projects the first one is I'm going to
say V CAG because I've lived in Germany
for five years I can do that so this is
kind of an older guidelines and this is
a set of recommendations for how we can
go about making the web more accessible
and it breaks down sorry at a higher
level we can kind of say it's these four
ideas so everything on the web page or
website should be perceivable okay
that's fairly clear so you should be
able to read the text it shouldn't be
hidden to obscurely or if there's video
or audio there needs to be alternate
content that explains what it's about
okay it should be operable yeah again
pretty straightforward we want people to
be able to navigate around our site so
you know don't have things where you
click and like the button runs away or
whatever you know pretty straightforward
understandable so this is about
providing user feedback and kind of
conforming to design patterns that allow
people to more or less know what they're
doing and robust so this is about a
forward compatibility and complying with
standards which we all do anyway so it's
divided into three priority levels and
this WCAG guidelines basically forms the
the basis for most legislation that's in
place I will talk about that a little
bit more so the problem with the WCAG is
when you really
going to break down what's going on
there it really is a lot of very very
kind of cross every T dot every I alt
text every image title every link and it
can feel like it's this incredibly
nitpicky approach where you just have to
be focused on all these tiny little
details and then you just start to think
oh my god life I work with the content
management system or I work with a
Content team or I there is no way I'm
ever going to be able to make sure every
single image on my site has an alt text
description I just it's too much it's
too hard I'm just going to give up and
walk away and unfortunately because this
is sort of underpinning the legislation
it's tended to be a little bit of a
turn-off for people so I think there's
some other ways we can think about that
which we'll talk about shortly as well
as the WCAG there's a new standard
called wa I aria and this is a
recognition that web pages aren't really
just the static documents that Tim
berners-lee envisaged you know 25 years
ago we have these really rich Internet
applications where things are being
updated or filtered or loaded in all the
time and it's very difficult to alert a
technology like a screen reader that
something's just changed on the page so
if your vision is fine and you're
looking you can easily see well like
something just loaded in there there's
been an update or whatever but if your
vision impaired and you're reliant on a
screen reader to basically read through
the page for you the web page needs some
way of saying well well well screen
reader come back up to the top of the
page there's like important news so WA
aria is the kind of a new specification
or relatively new that's trying to
reflect that and allow way basically for
us as developers to communicate or the
browser to communicate to assistive
technologies that something has changed
on the page
won't talk about too much I will skip
through the German legislation because
it's quite boring but I will talk a
little bit about the UK legislation
because i think the UK has taken a
slightly different approach which i
think is really really fantastic so the
there is one set of legislation which is
really based on this WCAG standard and
that's really like make sure your alt
text is there like make sure your links
have titles you know really black text
on a white screen thank you but they
also have this other document called the
pas 78 and if you're working on a
project where accessibility is an
important issue I cannot recommend
enough that you check this document out
that's it's it's quite short it's like
20 pages long it's non-technical it's
intended for a non technical audience
and the idea is how do you go about
planning a project for accessibility
from the very beginning and rather than
taking this really detail oriented
approach what the past 78 encourages you
to do is to say what is the main goal
for users of my website so this is a
really task oriented approach so if you
have an event booking website the most
important thing users on your site need
to be able to do is fill out that event
booking form if it's in marketing or
informational website the most important
thing is that people can read the
information and maybe fill out a contact
form so it's really from the very very
start of the project identifying when
people come to our website what action
do we want them to do what are they
coming here for and then making sure
that everybody regardless of ability can
complete that action so you might have
all this like amazing video and audio
content on your site and it's beautiful
and it's this really rich user
experience but if ultimately at the end
of the day you need to just convey a few
pieces of information and get someone to
fill out a form it's okay if you don't
subtitle all that video and audio it's
wonderful if you can but really put your
effort and you focus on your
belapur hours in making sure that these
key goals of the site can be achieved by
all users and I think what really is
wonderful about this is you see that
there's just such a really strong
crossover between what is good
accessibility to sign and what is good
UX kind of user experience design more
broadly they're really not something
that's like at loggerheads it's really
thinking from the ground up how do we
enable all users of our site to achieve
what they want to achieve ok cool that's
the background let's look at some code
so the first thing we're going to I
wanted to actually show you what a
screen reader sounds like but I have
this demo version of the software in it
it's just a bad day for audio up here so
maybe I'll just sort of demonstrate for
you who's actually listened to voiceover
on a mac or yeah a few people okay so
you have some idea of just how kind of
scary and aggressive that voice sounds
when I first started working on this
project and started to test I was just
like so horrified and shocked because on
a page like this what you basically get
is something like better accessibility
with JavaScript strict code mo wa I
landmark roles tab index and you're
sorry I'm sorry please don't terminate
the etch so it's really people who use
these screen readers to navigate the
internet I just have so much respect
because it's like straw denair alee
difficult and just this overwhelming
flow of information coming at you so
what we can do is actually make it a lot
easier so rather than it's just like one
long body of text that just gets read
out in this like huge stream well well
well where is the actual content of the
page we can start by marking up the
various areas of our page with these
things called wa I landmark roles and
this basically tells just going to
scroll down a little bit the screen
reader our voiceover or jaws or whatever
what the semantic role of
various parts of the document are so
this means that a user is able to
basically tab from the banner to the
navigation to the main to the
complementary to the content info
without having to read through
everything every time which is more or
less if you think about it how sighted
users are also scanning through the page
you know you might kind of read the top
part once you have two or three pages
into browsing a site you're not
rereading the navigation every time
you're jumping straight to that content
area and you're reading from there so
using these landmark roles which are
basically just attributes that you put
on you know the containing give or the
containing section or whatever you
wonderful html5 semantic container is
that you have you're basically just
marking up the page like this so kind of
very straightforward very easy to do and
if you're already using kind of these
html5 semantic elements then you know
that's kind of just meshes really well
with that next thing that you can do and
this is like really probably like almost
the most easy thing you can do to
improve the user experience of your
pages and that is to give a logical
tabindex to your pages now if you write
this beautiful from scratch handcrafted
HTML that's like flawless and this
polished gem of code then I am really
jealous of you but I work with WordPress
a lot so you time to end up with like
content that's being pulled in from all
over the place and you've got widgets
and you've got forms and you got this
near that and then they're all throwing
tab indexes into the content and what
that means is if I'm using the tab key
to basically move between the various
elements of the page I'm going to be
like appear and then I'm down there and
then i'm doing a form that I'm over here
and I don't know what I'm doing so let's
take all of that and let's just wipe it
back to zero so that when I tab through
the page and basically tabbing just
takes you from one focusable element to
the
X so generally from you know one link to
the next thing to the next thing then
I'm going to move through the page in a
logical order that makes it a lot easier
for me to understand and really that's
just this tiny handy snippet of code
here dump it in your in your projects
and you've just massively improved the
user experience for a whole group of
people so it's that easy folks but easy
another little useful fragment is this
one here which is the skip navigation
link so there's kind of some debate
about whether this is still necessary
now that we have these landmark roles
but you know what I think kind of err on
the side of caution and supporting
people who maybe have older technology
and all this basically is is a small
link that appears only when you focus on
it and it's just an in page length down
to the main content of the page so as
soon as I press tab and focus on the
link I can see it there I can press
Enter it will move the focus of the
screen reader down to the main content
and will start reading from there but if
you're a sighted user or you don't use
the keyboard to navigate the site you'll
never even know it's there so here's
just some CSS to show how you can hide
it yep okay
okay then screen reader text sometimes
you want to give a little bit of extra
information or context to people who are
using a screen reader so this might be
for example if you're as we're about to
see showing a map if you're looking at a
map this is really obvious to sighted
users it's a map it doesn't necessarily
come out that way when you're reading it
with a screen reader or you might have
something that has some specific type of
interaction that you have added an extra
keyboard control so for example to
filtering or to the carousel things like
this so you might just need to give a
little bit of context that's only
relevant to these users but you want to
hide it from sighted users so
unfortunately if you put display none on
something then a screen reader
technology is kind of smart enough to
know don't read that bit out so we have
to kind of do this very convoluted
little CSS snippet to basically have
text that's there in the right place and
will be read out by screen readers and
will be invisible to everybody else cool
so they're kind of some just little
small I mean I really think these are
small things that you can do that you
don't require you to like jump through
all the hoops that you need to get that
WCAG kind of certification stamp of
approval but really are going to help a
lot of people just have a much much
better experience on your site I've got
a few minutes left so in their final
minutes I'm just going to talk a little
bit about how or the approach that I've
taken to adapting some really common
libraries to just make the experience
for keyboard users and screen reader
users a little bit better and more fun
so as I said before this is definitely
not any kind of higher level amazingly
sophisticated code this is like this is
this is HTML email we're talking people
this is like
you have like all the different
operating systems and then how they
interact with all the different browsers
which then interact really differently
with all the different screen reader
software so testing for this and the
amount of quirks and just undocumented
bugs it's really a pain and quite ugly
so this is kind of some hacky approaches
to sort of making things a little bit
better which I hope you will find useful
so leaflet is a lovely open-source
mapping JavaScript library I use it a
lot if you do any kind of database stuff
it's really fantastic if you don't want
to just work with Google all the time
it's great unfortunately there's some
problems with how the leaflet library
works just sort of out of the box so
that one of the big things is that every
single one of the image tiles has an alt
text and that alt text is the latitude
and longitude of that particular image
tile so while you're reading through the
page and you're like that's great and
then there's a map and I can see there's
a map with some pins and some markers in
it if you're using jaws or voiceover
what you get is blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah 1743 22111 and you're like
what do I image 17 44 45 any like what
why did I just get half an hour of
numbers right out to me in this
meaningless stream which is obviously
like a really terrible user experience
so one of the ways I found to kind of
get rid of this was basically to for a
start don't know how where you can see
the code there but removing all the
images which are providing the shadows
on the markers because they don't really
need to be there and we don't really
need to hear the alt text of shadow we
also want to get rid of what I'm
actually doing there yeah so we're
setting this this all these other images
to have the role of presentation and
that signals to
screen readers that this is just here
for looks it's not content so don't read
it out finally we also have a problem
where if we are have these markers here
we don't necessarily have a really nice
kind of logical tab index so in this one
that I've kind of adapted a little bit
what we get here is when we click on the
marker the text inside the marker then
comes into focus so this tells the
screen reader you should now jump like
you were going to give focus to this
attribute and you should start reading
out from there then when I press tab I
get the close button so this is kind of
the opposite of how the leaflet library
does it by default and there's sort of a
bunch of code there that you can more or
less copy and paste and dumped into your
work if you're interested in using this
once I close I don't know if you can see
the blue kind of square around this but
my focus comes back to wherever I was
before I opened that marker so this is
just actually making all those kind of
markers on the page accessible to people
who are using a keyboard okay three
minutes and talk quickly about this
carousel so our carousel I mean what
picky carousel library this is mine I
like it so this is quite quite easy to
adapt so that you're also able to
control it using the left and right keys
of the keyboard so another thing we sort
of did here which I kind of found quiet
nice if I just tab through is that when
the item comes into focus we actually
then and only then show some additional
information that's for people who are
navigating using a keyboard so then once
this pops up and I can see all this
comes into focus the only reason why
this would come into focus is if
someone's tabbing through the page then
I'm going to give the
this ability to control it with the left
and right arrows and like most carousel
libraries are going to be exposing some
sort of previous and next event methods
so you can kind of tap into that and and
give that extra layer of keyboard
functionality I probably don't need to
look at that in much detail cool I yeah
I'll briefly show that what I do with
isotope again this is kind of just this
is like a really would be an awesome
case for using this Wa Aria stuff which
is supposed to kind of alert the screen
reader that there's like changes
appearing on the page but the support
for that is like pachi to non-existent
right now so maybe in kind of two years
time you'll be able to basically just
say the role of this kind of area is an
application and the screen reader should
automatically be kind of watching it and
checking for changes to the Dom but at
the moment it's not so we just kind of
came around to more or less hacking this
where when you select an element and it
gets a filter we just show a small kind
of little text here that says three
items found and focus is like shifted to
that so that if you're kind of using a
screen reader or your arm yeah if you're
if you need to use a screen reader you
can't see that there's only three items
that have been found because your vision
impaired instead we shift the focus to
hear and provide some other additional
feedback about what's happened as a
result of that filtering outcome no
filtering action okay um lost my slides
I have 14 seconds 13 but i will speak
very briefly about testing testing super
important do as much as it as you can of
course functionality testing you know
there's like as I said pick your battles
internet explorer but try to test with
as much technology as you can it's very
enlightening I think just to spend time
working with this software and just
seeing how challenging it is to use you
know if you're on a Mac it's as simple
as just hitting command in f5 and you
can get started straight away if you're
on Windows like me the only person in
the room you can download jaws and have
a play with that other really really
useful thing to do is task based testing
so this kind of comes back to what I was
talking about earlier about how you want
to identify user goals and make sure
people can actually fulfill them so it's
really awesome if you are able to work
with people who are have some disability
in some way and they're able to give you
feedback to set them tasks so to say go
to this page and make a booking find out
this contact information of this person
and see if they're actually able to
successfully complete those tasks or not
and then and only then elicit some
feedback about like what do you think
about the fonts and the colors and blah
blah blah because it's very subjective
but if someone's able to successfully
complete a task or not that's really
what you're interested in here so that's
my time thank you very much for
listening I hope you found something of
you
reject